as it is right now we're actually giving
you a pretty cool tool in the resume if
you want to make a map up here at the
bottom it's actually really easy let's
scroll down and take a look at it we can
see this great where I've lived in work
map here we can see place markers for
all the places where James has worked to
add this to your resume it's actually
pretty simple I'm going to open up dev
tools again and in the sources pane and
I've added this line to my resume
builder j/s I've added map div dot
append google map inside helper j/s
we've got some functions set up that
make it really easy for you to add a map
that automatically puts place markers
where you've lived and worked add this
to your code and see what happens the
functions in helper jsr using the JSON
that you created in resume builder
chassé it iterates through their
locations it runs Google searches on all
those locations and then uses the
results to put pins on the map it's
pretty awesome and there's actually
going to be a quiz in the practice
problems section after this lesson well
you'll be able to break it apart to see
how it works but beyond a Google map you
have tons of options for making your
resume interesting and interactive for
starters try editing the resume CSS to
style it the way that you want if you're
unfamiliar with CSS check out our course
on HTML and CSS it's in the instructors
notes or you can even use a library like
d3 to add a chart that helps people
visualize your skills I like that one
it's worth poking around d3 to check out
the really cool charts graphs and
visualizations you can easily add to
your resume and while you're at it check
out the links in the instructors notes
to other cool resumes we found online
get some inspiration and try customizing
yours